[Music]
let me tell you something that i i think
that you are going to like though
theovan has been
kind of taken shots at brendan lately on
the show
and here's a little super cut you're
well do you remember a long time ago
when we watched a clip together yeah
of
when brendan would just repeat theo's
jokes two seconds later yeah like over
and over again and he got very
frustrated it's one of the first times
i've ever seen theo vaughn be like come
on man like i just said that yeah just
doing it
backs dude no i don't talk to somebody
at starbucks dog no doctor barista bro
bro you don't even know you're an idiot
here we go
yeah and she crushes on only fans
yeah i don't know what kind of stuff
they're doing sure you don't
hold on it gets better
everybody knows you have accounts dude
he's calling him out for his burner
accounts because other people have
called them out for his burner instagram
accounts
uh-oh
you have sub-accounts you have other
accounts bobby has accounts in your name
okay this is good
i like the avon so
[Laughter]
we all know you get the fake laugh look
at the fake laugh
oh that bothered him you know that
bothered him that counts on there
okay
thank you theo [ __ ] thank you
jesus christ
you know the funniest thing ever would
be this keeps going on
until brennan bows up on theo
and like theo just surprisingly has just
a weird right hook yeah it takes him out
that he never uses but he used to use
all the time back in the day
that would be the most satisfying end of
this is brendan getting up theo getting
up and you'll be like theo is going to
get his ass beat and then there's just a
swing and brendan goes out and it's like
and then brendan's entire career is over
that would be the satisfying ending you
have to do a ronda rousey and re-brand
her himself and go to wwe
oh no
you want you want theovan to holly holm
him is what you're saying
kick him into another career
[ __ ] vince would would debut him as
thick boy but with a c properly spelled
yeah and [ __ ] trademarks yeah
whatever you guys have going on
[Laughter]
that's why you're funny theo jesus
christ
the shittiest game of clue
yeah both of them are really cute
actually i said this jelly roll's a
handsome guy he's and he's just so
lovable you just damn love him you know
oh yeah he can't help but love him oh
god get her off the screen jesus christ
[Music]
straight path see what this guy has to
say yeah here comes the guy who set up
the email account probably
[Laughter]
oh little digs
king the sting in the wing
face tats dude and let's put on some
weight
little face tats grow some beards i've
got so many problems
you don't need to add that to the plate
yeah the last thing i would need is that
dude i think for me you should get it
though
get something dude i might get someone
yeah you're considering all right yeah
it does look cool give your wife another
reason to be pissed brendan
man
man that was that was more than even a
playful pit that was a
oh
oh
can you feel a weird
because i think theo just wants to i
won't do my show man but i do think theo
just wants to do a show right and and
then yeah it feels like i'm getting i
don't even want to be in cali anymore
five seconds
look at his face honestly right
like
i think we need to make uh
i think we need to make a [ __ ]
we need to build florida as a place for
everybody to move to theovonne should
move farther i'm fine with that crisis
from tampa you you can come back to fly
yeah
let's start getting some people out of
la because i like this it breaks me i
was like i i hate this i don't want to
do i don't want to be this is legit i
don't want to be around anymore yep
hey when you go with a misspelled word
on your head
unbelievable it's just room you get
something like that
emojis jesus christ and what is this guy
doing he's making a beard
no frozen that's not me
it could be anybody it's a filter it
looks like a filter that's eric griffin
probably trying to get more money
[Laughter]
that's kind of funny
that's the new bank of america filter
he's actually going to disagree
business opportunity for you no
no no doubt she's
bradley martin he's filming something
with some dying piece girl in her hair
timepiece diamond piece alert die in
piece we need a diamond piece alert
dime piece dicey dicey she was short but
her hair was the longest hair you've
ever seen it was larry down to her
ankles so they're you know everyone's
getting water or something i'm working
out and i just went you have long hair
oh what she turns around no dude she
turns around what i go
uh your hair is crazy launches yeah no
[ __ ] i was like
good for her
that's all i got
she was like have a good day i was like
actually yeah okay you know what's all
about
yeah she's like you have long marriage
oh
what does he do what
what is he
what did what is this i didn't think it
was gonna keep he was gonna keep doing
this this this this went this went
pretty hard towards the end here huh
yeah
is just crazy you have a big nose thank
you thank you thank you have a good day
uh switch the topic so dude
talking to girls is always the hardest
thing to do
humans i talked to some girl out front
here about therapy for
an hour
therapy
therapy
dude what what
oh this guy added a bonus branding clip
okay this is good i love jelly roll baby
most malone they call it alone
i love seeing him man malone max yeah
well he just i mean you see jelly roll
he just uh
you know you just damn love him he's the
fifth season man yeah he's just a big
hug blurry hero's learning slurry hero's
worried you know what's crazy is my
sister can't even
read
but what does it have to do with us
right now hope you enjoyed that video no
i did thank you
i i you know theo i really did enjoy
that video thank you
he seems he's joking because he's he's a
comedian obviously but
he you could kind of feel
it's that weird end of o a vibe in the
room right
uh yeah i don't know man i feel like
that's just
he might be he might be at that part of
his life where
he's starting to look around at like the
whitney cummings is and the [ __ ] you
know what i mean like the [ __ ]
brian collins and the brendan schaabs
and all these [ __ ] sick crazy people
and i think he's just like i don't know
so what about
chris d stefano takes uh taking a shot
at brenda did you see this one
he was on a tiger belly
co-host as a matter of fact that's
mentioned in this clip oh really yeah i
like you know you and i came up well
with the first time i met you opie and
anthony those opie days of the comics
was just [ __ ] trashing each other ugh
it's just you you don't like those times
i do you miss those times oh my god now
now we got a guy who's gonna you know
they'll fight your car
just take the joke [ __ ]
i know i know how you get better i know
you don't think i want to see my friends
and family and other comics and peers
post stuff and stuff like that no i i
love that stuff
i left it was so toxic it was so evil
that i don't want to subscribe that
anymore and a lot of people can handle
social media god bless you man i wish i
could i'm too sensitive so
thank you for zooming in on his
rolex presidential
yes thank you
he's too sensitive he's suffering
because of
hold on
well i got something for you before we
move on
so you know the gentleman that made the
uh
made the jrc3 song
the score
yeah yes all right well i'm gonna post a
link in the chat so people could do it
but he made it he made a new song for us
you ready world premiere you ready
yeah
all right
[Music]
don't know what you're expecting of me
comedians don't
always have
[Music]
is
[Music]
can't you see that
[Music]
i can't even
is
[Music]
my words
[Music]
[Music]
actually
thank you and make sure to subscribe the
link's there right now i posted it yes
chad
thank you chad
thank you chad
all right enough brendan
for a little bit all right